when star wars the clone wars was
revived for a final season on disney
plus
fans of the series were ecstatic little
did they know they'd also be getting a
whole new follow-up series in star wars
the bad badge let's break down the first
episode of this new star wars chapter
first off order 66 everyone remembers
the infamous
order 66. what's order 66
also known as clone protocol 66 this is
a sith created order that brands jedi as
traders and subjects them to
execution emperor palpatine activates
this early on in the episode forcing the
bad batch to watch in horror as the rest
of the clone troops massacre the jedi
the sudden betrayal of the jedi plunges
the bad batch crew wrecker hunter echo
tech and crosshair into the universe's
brand new status quo as the republic
transitions into darth sidious galactic
empire it's later explained that the
genetic abnormalities of clone force
99's members mean their
inhibitor chips don't work properly
which instantly puts them at odds with
the rest of the imperial forces
the defective clones with the desirable
mutations
unfortunately their situation only gets
more desperate when grand moff tarkin
arrives on the aquatic planet kamino to
assess whether the empire really needs a
clone army choosing to investigate the
bad batch and their unique fighting
style but when they're dispatched to the
onderon sector under the pretense of
killing separatist insurgents the
batbatcher faced with a horrifying
realization
they were actually sent to kill republic
men women and children who disagree with
the empire and its fascist grip on the
galaxy
thankfully because the bad batch's chips
don't work they can't face carrying out
their mission rightfully choosing to
disobey their orders instead once again
it proves that their individual
personalities are their true strengths
in a fight of good vs evil
but it also means they failed the test
that tarkin set out for them will their
disobedience be the catalyst for the
empire ditching the clones for
conscripted civilians
quite possibly but we'll have to wait to
see in future episodes
unfortunately for the team there's one
soldier among them who isn't quite as
down with disobeying orders
good soldiers
unlike the other mutant clones crosshair
still wants to carry out the missions
he's been given even attempting to shoot
a jedi padawan in the introduction of
the bad batch episode 1. he constantly
butts heads with hunter the bad batch's
leader over the group not sticking to
their orders acting more like a typical
clone than
any of the others during the ondrawn
mission it becomes clearer that
crosshair's chip is still functioning to
some degree
as he votes to execute all the republic
outlaws it's likely that because his
genetics make his sharp shooting skills
even sharper they
also make him more amenable to taking
orders because of the sheer focus
required to be a sniper crosshair has to
be detached from the idea of killing
because he picks his targets off from a
distance which also explains why he has
such a cold
demeanor to make matters worse tarkin
and the kaminoans put crosshair's chip
into overdrive which forces him to fight
his own teammates during their escape
from the cloning facility he doesn't
exactly hold back
either directly taking aim at their
heads one shot nearly takes record down
crosshair even fires upon the innocent
clone child omega which perfectly
encapsulates just how far off the deep
end he's gone
luckily the team escapes from kamino
without crosshair and with omega but
thanks to crosshair's newfound loyalty
to tarkin and the empire it probably
isn't the last we've seen of them
right after the bad batch returns to
kamino we're introduced to omega a
mysterious young girl who also happens
to be a clone she's working under the
kaminoans as some kind of medical
apprentice although it's not exactly
clear why
because of the bad batch's unique
appearances and behavior omega instantly
feels a certain kinship with them
after all she's surrounded by thousands
of faces that all look the same
and yet has no one to connect with aside
from a helpful droid it's perfectly
understandable why omega is drawn to the
bad batch they're like her
that's the main reason why she leaves
kamino with them just like there's
nothing on kamino for the bad batch
anymore there's nothing there for omega
either as she points out she's never
been anywhere except the cloning
facility which makes flying around in a
spaceship
incredibly exciting the moment in the
cockpit where hunter watches as omega's
eyes widen at light speed travel shows
just how empathetic and compassionate
the clones can be
the relationship between an innocent
child like omega and the hardened
soldiers of the bad batch crew
also adds an excellent dynamic to the
series one that we've seen work wonders
in the star wars universe before
looking ahead both omega and the bad
batch will be forced to grow and develop
in new ways because of their partnership
omega's naivete will push the bad batch
to be even more empathetic and steady in
their convictions and the bad batches
boldness bravery and connections to
people in places all over the galaxy
will open omega up to a whole new life
where have we seen that before the
mandalorian would like a word
now that the bad batch have been branded
as traders they can no longer call
kamino their home
sparking a brand new adventure for them
to embark on but this raises a number of
questions
since they all have similar facial
features to other clones it's going to
be very difficult keeping a low profile
among the current imperial forces
because they'll be instantly
recognizable
this is likely why they're seeking help
from an old friend as hunter puts it but
it's not quite clear who it is they're
looking for
while it would be easy to assume that
they're looking for commander rex since
the squad worked alongside him in the
clone wars season seven
it's not that simple the bad batch has
no way of knowing if his chip has forced
rex into an imperial minion or not and
it would be a big gamble to just assume
that he'd be able and willing to help
them in a post-order 66 world whoever
hunter's friend
is they live in sector j19 also called
the seleucomy system
the sector was seen way back in the
clone wars season 2 where a clone
deserter named cutler queen lives a
peaceful life on a farm
could this be the person the bad batch
is going to meet up with it's not
impossible that dave filoni and the star
wars the bad batch writers are calling
back to earlier plots and characters in
the series over the course of this new
show but only time will reveal who's
going to ally with the squad
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one